if you want to learn how to hack your
life by mastering your energy setting
triggers and tricking yourself on how to
interpret things then this video is for
you if you master this everything else
you can dream of is available to you and
if you fail to master this everything
else goes to the wayside and having new
goals without new habits is kind of like
you know having a new car without wheels
you know the habits are the wheels they
are the things that make you able to
achieve the goals when you used to speak
in front of a large audience and
somebody'd say how do you feel you say a
little nervous now when somebody says
how do you feel I'm like really excited
actually
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing potential that
you have inside you that I want to see
explode out into the world so to help
you on your journey today we're gonna
learn five life hacks that everybody
should know about enjoy life hack number
one is use the five-second rule with Mel
Robbins number one your life happens in
five-second windows number two in five
seconds you can control what you think
you can decide what you're going to do
and you can change absolutely anything
which changes absolutely everything and
so the five-second rule is a mind trick
that's all that it is a fancy way to
call it as a you know it's a form of
metacognition but it's basically a hack
it's a cheat code okay and the way that
it works and this is the challenge with
getting it out there is that it sounds
so profoundly stupid like a gimmick that
it took a while for people to actually
take it seriously I get that and to
really stack up the science to make you
know anybody that interacts with it go
wholly like this actually works yeah so
here's what it is basically the moment
you catch yourself hesitating or
doubting or starting to worry or about
to chicken out or shrink or shut up or
whatever it is that you're about to do
that is
shrinking your power you just go 5 4 3 2
1 you count backwards 5 4 3 2 1
what happens when you do that don't do
it out loud because it'll scare somebody
it's like going by counting backwards
the the kind of cheat code that you're
doing in your mind is you are
interrupting what are called habit loops
that get encoded in the central part of
your brain and you are starting up the
prefrontal cortex it's a little trick
that causes focus and it's it's a lot
like having a mantra because you're
shifting gears but the thing about
having a mantra is and I suppose that as
you count backwards more and more and
more you become used to it but it
becomes a habit that triggers action so
what you do is go 5 4 3 2 1 cut off this
part of the brain awaken this part of
the brain and then move and what happens
with the counting backwards is there's
nowhere to go after 1 and your mind
is socialized in a countdown situation
to go and so counting up won't work
because you can keep it forever and you
do it in many aspects of your life so
it's actually not something that
requires any focus life hack number 2 is
run the 9091 rule with Robin Sharma so
for the next 90 days your first 90
minutes at work make it focused on your
single most important project I'll
repeat that again for the next 90 days
the first 90 minutes of your work day
focus Mono maniacally on your single
most valuable project I call it your
game changing move so it might be it
might be creating a new piece of code
that will revolutionize the marketplace
it might be a new product that when
launched it will fill a need within your
industry that no peer is currently
providing I don't know what your game
changing move is but this is your poetry
this is your magnum opus for the next 90
days so what most people do is you know
people who are playing at victimhood
people who are in the ninety five
percent people who are making excuses
about ordinary results in their life a
lot of them are not doing the things
that would give them legendary results
and what they do is they get to the
office and rather than using prime time
for a activities they use their best
hours watching dancing cats on whatever
it is whatever the video platform is
they spend their best hours surfing the
internet looking at blogs they spend
their best hours playing with
notifications reading notifications
chatting with friends who are not really
their friends but really they're just
bored so they're distracting themselves
which is just a form of medication
because potential unexpressed
turns to pain and they're in a lot of
pain and it's subconscious and they
haven't done the work to know it so
really they've created these drugs of
choice like too much email too much web
surfing too much chit chatting too much
looking at funny looking videos that
make them laugh in the moment that make
them feel happy and give them a short
burst of dopamine and maybe a little bit
of serotonin which is the pleasure
neurotransmitter and that's how they get
through their day and all I'm saying is
there's so much distraction available to
you out there that if you are not
acutely careful it will dominate your
days what I'm really trying to say is
this a ritual for you to run and dial in
and hardwire to the point of
automaticity that's the word the
researchers use when a habit becomes
your new normal over 66 days is the 1991
rule and to give it to you again so you
really remember it for the next 90 days
your first 90 minutes create a tight
bubble of total focus so that no one can
distract you turn off your devices put
them
a little plastic bag put some reminders
on your door maybe some post-it notes
that this is my type bubble of total
focus for the next 90 minutes tell your
team tell your loved ones maybe get it
put a Do Not Disturb sign on your door
they'll laugh and explain it to them
that for the next 90 days I will spend
90 minutes away from distraction away
from technology away from interruptions
focusing on my magnum opus focusing on
the genius project that I want to bring
into the world because I will never mail
it in I will always bring it on
and I'm gonna do this for the next 90
minutes and I'm gonna optimize it and
iterate it every day and I'm gonna bring
my full bandwidth because what makes a
genius they all have one trait in common
they were able to spend extended periods
of time in isolation focused mono
maniacally on their most valuable
project life hack number three is master
your energy with Tony Robbins if you
master this everything else you can
dream of is available to you and if you
fail to master this everything else goes
to the wayside I mean I need to have all
the time in relationships they want
relationship therapy it I I see you know
you got to do you gotta exercise you got
to work out you got to lose some weight
you guys are just so tired there
couldn't possibly be any passion
well you're exhausted there is no
passion you'll say okay well I'm gonna
really work on a plan and I'm gonna
organize things I'm gonna find the best
trainer and you know I come back I'm
talking to my week later and they're
still planning things this woman's
telling me no but I'm gonna get the best
trainer the very best training organized
this I said ma'am with all due respect
you don't need a plan you need a trainer
you need somebody gets behind you just
yell
you'll need this long plan he's got
moves
no we're living in a society where
nobody moves anymore what do we like
today well how do people get injured
today they don't get injured smashing in
the people playing football nothing else
to get into you're typing it's you know
picking up a pencil oh oh that really oh
that's some people get hurt today
because we don't use everything anymore
we live in the box think about it think
about our lives today and how different
it is that may be the way we are formed
and made to run behind to create to
procreate to raise our children to move
to form to do all the things that made
us use all of our body today what do we
do you wake up and you have this box
life you have a box breakfast I hate you
get your box car you drive your box
office you'd float up a box elevator you
don't use the stairs of course right you
go to your box office well you type on a
box talk in a box right go into a box
room for meetings right sure enough got
a little box you can type on listen to
listen to music unbox have your box
lunch drive your box home or get in the
train or subway and another box home get
home to your box and then turn on the
Box type on the box message on the box I
mean and maybe go get a cylinder to
change your state maybe and most
people's idea of exercise in our society
today is fill the tub pull the plug and
fight the current
but that's not the role we live in today
and so it's not hard to figure out why
we're getting fat and why we're finally
kind of tired and why we're building up
acid in our system consuming foods that
have nothing alive in them anymore
where everything is be nurtured and
everything is chemicalized or radiated
so it can feel overwhelming but I think
if we got back to our common sense and
if we were really committed we can make
it all work and I want I'm trying to say
to you is really simply this this
morning I'm gonna take the morning and
not talk to you about how to do this
we're gonna figure out why - because 80%
of success in anything is psychology and
20% is mechanics if the beliefs you have
that are guiding your decisions listen
if you make a different decision will
you take different actions yes or not if
you take different actions will you get
different results yes or no so this day
is about some new decisions some
decisions about what you're gonna
believe about health and energy how
important it's gonna be from you for now
what's gonna be a must for you versus a
should feel energy is place without more
than been right now I want to make sure
that you have even more I want to make
it so that it's as effortless as
possible in the future so you're not
burnout from it so this becomes a
sustainable experience how do you make
it sustainable create the base how to
make a sustainable challenge it once you
got a base you challenge and grow how do
you do it then you got to celebrate and
reward yourself for making these great
rewards and that celebration enhances
your base because you feel better and
stronger and you want to do even more
good things you want to eat better you
want to play better and we start working
out and you start to get into it you
love it you love it and then your base
gets even stronger so you can take on a
bigger challenge in life and sure enough
you reward yourself and celebrate some
more and it becomes how the rich get
richer how the happy get happier how the
healthy get healthier and the poor get
poorer and the depressed get more
depressed and they on how to get more
unhealthy it's momentum today is that
process of momentum life fact number
four is set trigger moments to sustain
your habits with Brendon Burchard I know
you all have big goals big dreams big
aspirations just like I do
you've got ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create to contribute to give to be an
awesome human being
but all of that is impossible without
great habits set up if you don't have
routine and structure set up in a way
that will keep you on track then you'll
fall often and having new goals without
new habits is kind of like you know
having a new car without wheels
you know the habits are the wheels they
are the things that make you able to
achieve the goals so you got to have
good habits but the challenge for most
people isn't that knowledge I mean you
know you need to have a good habits it's
you can't keep the habit going right
have you ever started at the new year
you're gonna get healthier and you start
that habit of working out wanna more
regular basis and then it goes away or
you say you know I'm gonna be more kind
and more patient and more awesome to my
partner my lover and you start being
nice for two or three days and then on
the fourth day you're a jerk you know
and you're like wow what happened I said
I was gonna be nicer it's that you
didn't set up the most important thing
you needed to maintain a habit so what's
the biggest secret I've learned in
almost 20 years in this field it's so
simple but most people don't have it
it's called trigger moments you have to
set up trigger moments to activate your
habits what do I mean by that well let's
say you want to become a better person
you know you want to become more kind
more patient more loving with people now
you can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision or your journal
or set up on a vision board that you
look at once in a while but in day to
day life it's not enough you need things
to trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be you
would obviously become better well that
makes sense well let's use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this can be so
basic you're gonna laugh and then also
tell you how I've literally taught this
to fortune 50 CEOs and they said it was
the one thing that changed their life
the most dramatically so let's start
with this let's say I have a goal in
mind let's say you want to become
more present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm gonna be more present and
calm you could meditate in the mornings
like today I'm gonna be more present and
calm and you could you could start out
with good intentions but those fall
apart without a trigger moment set up
throughout the day to remind you that so
what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said close
your eyes take ten deep breaths in
remind yourself to be calm so let's say
you're going through your day it's crazy
right it's 10:00 a.m. and all since
being your phone goes off you look down
and it says close your eyes take ten
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
p.m. and again it happens at 8 p.m.
what's gonna happen you always look at
your phone don't you it's gonna go
throughout the day you're gonna forget
and the funniest thing is I've had so
many people do this worldwide we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
people I've talked to do this hundreds
of thousands and they tell me all the
time that that changed everything and
you'll think once you set it up that the
next day you'll you'll forget about it
know that alarm will go off you forgot
you set the dang alarm there goes off in
your face you're like all right I'm
trying to be calmer and more present
close my eyes take ten deep breaths
reground myself here we go you can't do
it once a day you have to have moments
throughout the day that trigger you to
enact to the new behavior I know this
makes sense to you but it's a challenge
for a lot of people because they never
set those things up so what if you did
it with an alarm so for example for me
on the opposite spectrum I don't want to
just be calmer and more present
I want more energy throughout the day so
here's what I do one of my big trigger
moments is every time my butt hits a
chair I don't care if I'm on a plane or
I was like where we're shooting here I
wrote a lot of my books here I wrote the
motivation manifesto here I wrote the
charge here and if I'm going to write my
buttons hits the chair I grab my phone I
open the timer and I set 50 minutes now
at 50 minutes the
starts buzzin and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water or drink it down I do
some stretches and I do some exercise
just really briefly or I'll go for a
walk whatever it is but I'll do
something that usually takes just 2 to 5
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 min alarm and I'll work and what
that does is every 50 minutes it
triggers me to change how I'm physically
moving it changes my attention so that
throughout the day I'm continually
refreshed so I never have that 2 3 4
clock time or my ah you know why because
I've triggered my day some of that my
energy is maintained throughout the day
makes sense right this could be as
simple as let's say you want to be
healthier in your life ok let's set up
some trigger moments for you in this way
let's say every time you drop off the
kids on the way back to the house you
stop at the grocery store and get some
fresh produce that's just a trigger it's
like okay did one thing drop kids off
now tied to that triggered from that
action drop kids off is go to health
food store or let's say you want to get
healthier in the morning one of the
easiest ways to help people maintain a
better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on might get dressed if
you're naked just saying so you get
dressed
put your shoes on you go downstairs or
you go to the gym and that's the trigger
you woke up you do these actions nothing
interrupts those actions that's the
action and you have to have those set up
one of my other favorite trigger moments
to set up is doorframe triggers what do
you know that when you walk into a new
room to have a psychological trigger go
off in your mind that you've associated
with that doorframe let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after light if I've been working all day
and I'm gonna walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house
three words repeat off immediately in my
mind because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walked through a
door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was how people
described you what would those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life
I teach executives to do this as well I
have them have a doorframe trigger when
they walk into their office in the
morning as soon as they walk through
that door frame they have boom three
words go through their mind about how
they want to be perceived as a leader I
have them set up another door for every
time they walk into a meeting into the
conference room when they walk through
the doors of the conference room they
have another three words that trigger
off for them and it just reminds them
how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people they think they
have to completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
and life hack number five is interpret
pressure as excitement with simon Sinek
I was watching the Olympics this last
Summer Olympics and I was amazed at how
bad the questions were that the
reporters would ask all the athletes and
almost always they asked the same
question whether they were about to
compete or after they competed were you
nervous right and to a tee all the
athletes went no right and what I
realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies I mean what it what happens
when you're nervous right your heart
rate starts to go your you know you sort
of get a little tense you get a little
sweaty
right you have expectation of what's
coming and we interpreted that is I'm
nervous now what's the interpretation of
excited your heart rate starts to go you
become you're anticipating what's coming
right you get a little sort of like
tense it's all the same thing it's the
same stimuli except these athletes these
these Olympic quality athletes have
learned to interpret the stimuli that
the rest of us would say is nervous as
excited they all say the same thing no
I'm not nervous I'm excited and so I've
actually practiced it just to tell
myself when I start to get nervous that
this is excitement you know and so where
when you used to be speaking for the
large audience and somebody'd say how do
you feel I should say a little nervous
now when somebody says how do you feel
like really excited actually and it it
came from just sort of telling myself no
no this is excitement and it becomes a
little bit automatic later on but it's
kind of a remarkable thing to deal with
pressure by interpreting what your body
is experiencing as excitement rather
than nerves and it's really kind of
effective it makes you want to rush for
is rather than pull back and yet it's
the same experience so there's a lot of
life hacks here it's hard to pick my
favorite I love them all I would say
though probably number four is my
favorite the one with Brendon Burchard
around setting triggers to reinforce
your habits the door frame exercise
where you walk into a room and every
time you see this doorframe and you
remind yourself of something it's
something I've had on my radar I've
heard him say that a number of times
it's not my radar it's one of those
things that eventually so leave I slowly
it's wearing me down it's gonna happen
and I'll find a way to apply it into my
life so that would be my favorite but I
would love to know which one did you
guys like the most which one are you
gonna apply to your life and had the
biggest impact please leave you down the
comments below I'm really looking
forward to hearing from you so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your own word is
much love I'll see you soon raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that means that people need
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details